oh you Malcolm I'm doing fine that just
I'll give you the floor how I feeling
what's going through your mind man I
mean I feel great you know it's it's
been a long year man one that taken a
lot of sacrifice a lot of work a lot of
trust and safe for us to be able to
bring that Lombardi Trophy back to the
city of Philadelphia that you know we
wouldn't actual for a better pleasure so
let's take that one at a time here okay
sacrifice but watch what do you guys
what do you refer to when you say that
what sacrifices
well we think about what the team you
know was able to start doing you know
back in OTAs in April in a commitment
that we made
you know voluntary workouts the OTAs
training camp throughout at the time
during the season you know not only on
the field but off the field with time
away from the family the time we
invested in each other the relationships
all of that takes you know sacrifice and
uh you know it's times like this where
you get to go back to kind of where you
lay that foundation and to what do you
refer with trust and faith and Malcolm
interesting fate comes you know when
trials come and adversities come we lost
so many players you know before we even
made it to the carson wentz part we had
already lost our All Pro probably Hall
of Fame tackle in the left tackle we
also lost Darren Sproles Hall the
campaign returner we lost Chris Mayer
those who you know arguably is one of
the best attributes players and we lost
our starting kickers while started
middle linebacker so you talking about
you know all these leaders captains and
we had to have enough faith that the
next guy was going to come in and
perform rather trust each other to do
our jobs on have faith in and our team
of what we were capable of and then at
the end of the year you lose Cardinal
inch and all those lessons that we have
it really built this for the stage
Malcolm Jenkins here in the Rich Eisen
show so what role did you play in in
maintaining all of that trust faith what
where did you fit into this equation do
you think that means for me as a leader
on the team I think it was
very important for me to just you know
be the same guy every day oh we got some
young guys in a team but we had a lot of
veterans as well and I think you know
younger guys in a team usually look at
the veterans in hard times to see how
they react and when they look at us they
see myself Chris long our Sean Cecily
Brandon Graham such a Cox just going
about our work like I like everything is
cool then they usually follow suit and
that's kind of what we did all year is
just kind of focus on the task at hand
what about was practice preparation in
the game one week at the time and just
going to compete and having more fun
than anybody else in this league and it
was so for me it was really really easy
even with other things going on around
us being able to have all these other
leaders in veterans won games before
then in these situations made it very
very easy for any leader in this locker
room well let's talk about the things
going on around you Malcolm and
obviously the social activism the
protest the President of the United
States chiming in time and time again do
you feel a sense of vindication that at
the end of the day you're the ones
hosting the Lombardi Trophy in a
situation where many people thought that
what you were doing was a negative draw
a distraction vindication I think you
know internally we've had a team you
know full of players at us that has been
active in our communities that has been
speaking out on in justices and we've
had a great environment I think everyone
has been watching to see if that was
going to be a distraction and a blur in
our locker room and it hadn't been you
know and the point wasn't and so I think
right now we're in an example that
athletes can can be active in their
communities they can speak up use their
voices have other interests and still
focus on the game and still have success
as a team it's not divisive it's not a
distraction like they'd like to paint it
if anything I think all of the things
that have happened off the field this
year has brought us closer together as a
team um even with all the attention that
we've got and we've been able to him you
know amplify the platform that we shot
on the gift
a couple more things with on this
subject with the Walter Payton Man of
the Year nominee from the Philadelphia
Eagles Malcolm Jenkins you have already
been on record that you do not intend if
you are invited to go to the White House
correct okay now do you is there a part
of you though that just thinks that
maybe you should go and you get a minute
with this with with the president and
and face-to-face eye-to-eye tell them
what what what what what your point of
view is and perhaps have a conversation
if that's possible yeah I've heard you
know people bring that up like this is
an opportunity to to speak but I've won
a Super Bowl when I was in New Orleans
and that does not have these ships
though you know these are the
celebratory in nature and it's really
just a photo-op
the team is there the president comes in
takes the figures and present at least
it's not like there's time to have a
sit-down meeting or conversation no or
one of those environmental settings so
when it comes to a photo-op I'm just not
interested in the photo-op but I've been
very interested from the beginning and
working with legislators and lawmakers
will provide us at their party about
these changes that we're trying to make
and I'm still open to that and still
engaging in those practices so this has
nothing to do with politics I'm just
simply not interested in the photo-op so
what would you say to him though Malcolm
if you did get two minutes three minutes
five minutes twenty minutes what would
you say my conversation would be the
same the reason that players have put
themselves out there in front of the
world is because we want to make our
communities better we've seen the
effects that our criminal justice system
is had on communities of color and we
want to change that we want to end mass
incarceration we're gonna in the back I
just want to stop sending juveniles to
life without parole
we've seen the comments videos of people
being killed you know Billy for nothing
by police officers we want to change our
relationship between our communities and
our law enforcement we want
accountability and we've seen the
differences in our educational system
and economic opportunities in these
different communities and we want to be
able to make a country that is fair and
just and provides opportunities for
anybody no matter what color they are
Malcolm Jenkins here on the Rich Eisen
show let's move to the game now in Super
Bowl 50 - what do you think you were
able to accomplish in this game that
helped put you over the top
well 100 a just between the ability to
play call guys making some some great
plays great catches bronze Knicks old
slam out of his mind and then getting in
a shootout you know with Tom Brady
defensively we realized early we got a
few stops time needed and then late in
the game we knew all we needed was one
play and we got it right there at the
end Brandon Graham justice trip debo
knight scoops it up and in first that's
that's it was fitting because all year
we just we told ourselves we then had to
be pretty doesn't have to be a blowout
anything like that I would you need to
find a way and that's exactly what we
did
as the only Malcolm in the secondary in
this game to play I'm wondering do you
have two cents on on the Malcolm Butler
benching as it appears and how it
affected things because a lot of people
think that him being active might have
changed the Patriots fortunes wondering
what you think on that Malcolm Jenkins
player I think he's been a starter for
them for a reason
so I know even when we saw him not on
the field we were all shot you know and
that's players coaches and everything
because we understand that he's probably
the best or second-best corner depending
are you looking at I'm sort of not have
him in that game the biggest game of the
year would put everything on the line
I'm not sure what it was that kept him
off for Eric Lee I was definitely
surprised yeah like I said he's probably
their best option I think we were
preparing for him to be on one of our
premier guards and obviously we're not
out there we feel really good about
those not Josh and you know nick foles I
got to meet him at a Super Bowl a couple
years ago after he had initial success
with Chip Kelly and I got to meet him
and I really enjoyed just a small brief
chat I had with him
I'm really beginning to learn a lot more
about him what he had to say after the
game about how using failure is an
ability to make yourself better and the
way he composed himself and played the
last few weeks the he he's got a fan for
life and me and I know a whole Legion of
other people what what did what what
have you learned about Nick Foles
Malcolm Jenkins well it has probably the
toughest kid in our locker you know for
him to be thrown into a situation like
he was where you know the seasons wrong
and everything is looking great all of a
sudden we lose the quarterback and he's
thrown in and now you know the success
of the team at least to everybody else
outside of them seems to be hanging on
his shoulders you know he plays really
well against the Giants threw four
touchdowns and RDS couldn't stop anybody
and everything was great it was a great
high and then all of a sudden you know
those struggles and everybody's down you
know not only him for the success of the
team and so he's carrying that burden
but I had enough you know strength and
faith in themselves to to distrust
process I think you realized that his
teammates were behind them that we had
trusted them that we started to get the
job done any just went to work then and
blocked out all of ourselves and played
lights out for us over the last and what
did it mean how did it permeate the
sidelines when Doug Peterson went for it
on fourth down those two times he's been
aggressive all year so it wasn't uh it
wasn't one of those things that was
surprising at that point a game you know
we felt like he's taking probably more
riskier calls than that one in the past
that one as soon as Nick kind of walked
over to the side we all recognized will
play here just cause they have practice
here for a few weeks
we were China they were going to run
that in the NFC Championship with every
that allowed to it and we knew that one
that will probably work so it was I'm
glad that Nick caught the ball and
lastly for you Malcolm look I mean just
as everything that we we've talked about
about this team and foals and Wentz and
your coach and you know how it was all
playing out on that field that my
favorite part about this and you just
tell
what you think and if I'm wrong I'm a
fun way off my favorite part about all
this is when it all came down to it when
you needed that play you turn to a
Michigan man to get the turnover on
defense Malcolm and that's what you
needed that's my favorite and that's
that what's that when the Patriots
needed it all on the line even after a
great game the guy who went to Michigan
lost the ball the way I look at it too I
guess I guess it all works out on the
calls I'm fourth down for you Malcolm
right and one last one for you we
noticed there were no touchdown
celebrations for any celebrations at all
in the Super Bowl did you guys have
anything planned it just didn't come up
what what was that because you guys were
really good at that all year long yeah I
think the situation was just a little
bit cause of the look of more
seriousness yeah we were still locked in
uh yeah I don't think anybody was
planning any celebration
well hey Malcolm like I told you really
love the way that you handle conduct
your business do go about it when you're
in Los Angeles again the the chair to my
right on my desk is always open for you
have a great time at the parade and
we'll chat soon hopefully you got it the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience